BREAKING NEWS ON THIS
SEX OFFENDER CREEP IN NEW YORK
WHO SUCKER PUNCHED A MAN
FRACTURING HIS SKULL AND NEARLY
KILLING HIM.
HE IS FINALLY BACK BEHIND BARS
WHERE HE BELONGS.
THE ARREST HAPPENED IN ONLY
AFTER A MAJOR PUBLIC OVER LACKS
BAIL LAWS THAT LET HIM ROAM
AROUND THE BIG APPLE TODAY.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR KATHY HOGLE
ACTING LIKE IT WAS HER IDEA.
NEVER MIND AS "NEW YORK POST"
COVER THAT CALLED HER OUT.
>> I TOOK ACTION INTO MY OWN
HANDS.
I DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION TO IMMEDIATELY
EXAMINE WHETHER OR NOT TO THIS
PAROLE VIOLATION OCCURRED, YES,
IT DID.
YOU CAN TELL THAT IT OCCURRED.
THIS IS A PERSONAL LIFETIME
PAROLE AND AS OF MINUTES AGO,
THAT PERSON IS NOW IN CUSTODY.
THAT IS AT MY DIRECTION.
THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK NEED TO
KNOW THAT AS OUR GOVERNOR I WILL
STAND UP AND PROTECT THEM.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT THIS WAS
JUST ONE OF THE MANY CRIMES THAT
HAVE HAPPENED UNDER HER WATCH.
VIDEO OBTAINED BY
"THE NEW YORK POST" SHOWS BRAZEN
THIEVES ROBBING A COFFEE SHOP
AND CUSTOMERS ACT GUNPOINT,
RIGHT ACROSS FROM THE OFFICE OF
THE TOP DEFUND A POLICE
POLITICIAN.
AND THE DEMOCRATS CARNAGE DOES
NOT END THERE.
IT'S COMPLETE ANARCHY IN
LOS ANGELES.
VIDEO SHOWING A FLASH MOB
RANSACKING A 7-ELEVEN AND
LEAVING THE PLACE IN SHAMBLES.
ALL RIGHT, KATIE, I WILL START
WITH YOU.
I CAN'T GET OVER THE CHUTZPAH OF
THIS GOVERNOR.
I DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS -- UH, IT CERTAINLY
SEEMS LIKE A VIOLATION.
GOVERNOR, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
OR WHATEVER RESPECT YOU THINK
YOU ARE ENTITLED TO, THIS WAS AN
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
THE POLICE MADE AN ARREST.
A PROGRESSIVE D.A. MADE A
DECISION TO LOWER THAT FROM AN
ATTEMPTED MURDER TO A
MISDEMEANOR, ASSAULT 3 WHICH IS
NOT A BAIL-ELIGIBLE CRIME.
LET'S BE CLEAR JUST FOR THE
VIEWERS, THIS MAN SUFFERED A
FRACTURED SKULL, A BROKEN
CHEEKBONE, A BRAIN BLEED.
HE IS IN A COMA.
THIS WAS TOTALLY UNPROVOKED.
THE DIRTBAG WHO DID IT RIGHT
THERE ON CAMERA, YOU CAN PUT
THIS IN FRONT OF A JURY AND TELL
THEM TO RUN THE TAPE AND THEN GO
TO THE DELIBERATION ROOM AND
VOTE.
THIS DIRTBAG IS A SEX OFFENDER
LEVEL 3.
LEVEL 3 MEANS HE IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS, HE IS THE MOST LIKELY
TO REOFFEND, AND HE HAS A DANGER
TO THE COMMUNITY.
HE IS NOT ONLY A SEX OFFENDER,
HE IS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN
CONVICTED OF SEVERAL FELONY
CRIMES.
NOW, THIS OBVIOUSLY THE REASON
THAT SHE WANTS TO TAKE CREDIT IS
BECAUSE SHE IS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE, RIGHT?
DOES SHE DESERVE CREDIT?
>> Katie: CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU PUT ONE GUY BACK IN JAIL
AFTER HE WAS LET OUT AND SHOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN LET OUT, GIVEN
THAT YOU SAW HIS MUG SHOT AND
MANY OF THEM ON THE SCREEN.
HE COULD HAVE HURT SOMEONE ELSE
IN THE TIME THAT HE WAS OUT OF
JAIL, AND AS YOU SAID, CHARGES
ARE BEING LOWERED PAIRED WHICH
MEANS THAT THERE IS NO
DETERRENCE NEXT TIME AROUND FOR
HIM OR OTHER
CRIMINALS WATCHING THOSE WHO
ARE SAYING WELL, IF I
DO SOMETHING HEINOUS LIKE THIS I
CAN JUST GET OFF AND NOT BE
PROSECUTED BY THE SYSTEM.
SHE IS RUNNING AGAINST
LEE ZELDIN WHO IS A REPUBLICAN
RUNNING ON A TOUGH ON CRIME
POLICY POSITION.
THAT'S WHY SHE HAS TAKEN US INTO
HER OWN HANDS.
IT'S A GOOD THING THIS GUY IS
BACK BEHIND BARS.
SHE COULD DO BIGGER THINGS LIKE
FIRE THE PROGRESSIVE D.A. IN
NEW YORK CITY.
AND ALSO GENERALLY SPEAKING, THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE WAY THAT THE
CRAM DILEMMA CRIME HAS RUN
RAMPANT AND OUT OF CONTROL, THE
FURTHER ALONG IT GETS, THE
FURTHER ALONG THESE SOLUTIONS
ARE GOING TO BE EXTREME.
SO NEW YORK NEEDS A MAYOR NOT
LIKE ERIC ADAMS WHO TALKS A LOT
ABOUT FIGHTING VIOLENT CRIME AND
IS NOT DOING MUCH TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
THEY NEED SOMEONE LIKE RUDY
GIULIANI.
NO PAUL LEWIN TOLERANCE
POLICIES, AND REALLY GOING AFTER
THESE GUYS.
IT'S DETERRENCE AND NO TOLERANCE
FOR CRIMINAL RIGHTS, BUT RATHER
MORE EMPOWERMENT OF VICTIMS AND
PREVENTING THIS FROM HAPPENING.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE POINT
THAT KATIE MAKES IS A GOOD ONE,
TYRUS, AND THAT'S THAT WE HAVE
THESE LIBERAL D.A.'S.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A BRONX
CASE.
AND THE BRONX D.A. IS THE ONE
THAT MADE THE DECISION TO REDUCE
IT TO A MISDEMEANOR.
WHAT IS CRAZY ABOUT THIS, TYRUS,
IS THAT NEW YORK CITY COPS SAID
THIS IS ATTEMPTED MURDER.
I'M TELLING YOU IT IS ATTEMPTED
MURDER.
NOW, IF THEY REDUCED IT TO A
MISDEMEANOR, THERE WILL BE A
PUBLIC OUTCRY BECAUSE OF -- THEY
MADE IT ESSENTIALLY BAIL
ELIGIBLE.
NOW THEY SAY THEY ARE STILL
INVESTIGATING.
IF THEY ARE STILL INVESTIGATING
IT, WHY DID THEY REDUCE IT TO A
MISDEMEANOR AND LET THE GUY OUT
ON THE STREET?
>> Tyrus: WE ARE STILL
INVESTIGATING MEANS, OH, WOW,
PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS.
WHO FILMED IT?
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
REAL ISSUE IS IS INTEND TO.
THIS DUTY -- THIS IS NOT TWO
GUYS THAT GOT INTO AN ARGUMENT
AND A FIGHT BROKE OUT AND A GUY
GOT PUNCHED IN HIS DRAWER BROKE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SAW HIS
VICTIM, PUT GLOVES ON, MEASURED
THEM UP, AND LAID THEM OUT.
THAT IS INTENDED.
THAT IS STRAIGHT UP INTENT.
HE PLANNED IT AND THEN HE DID
NOT RUN AWAY, HE DID NOT STAND
IN FEAR.
HE STAND OVER HIM AND THEN
CASUALLY STROLLED OFF.
YOU CAN MAKE ARGUMENTS OFF A
POLITICAL PEOPLE ALL YOU WANT
TO, BUT THE EMBRACEMENT OF THE
DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT, WE
ARE SEEING PREMEDITATED BRAZEN.
THAT GROUP THAT ROBBED A
7-ELEVEN, THAT WAS PLANNED
PAIRED THAT WAS BY A FACEBOOK
PARTY.
CRIMINALS ARE EMBOLDENED BECAUSE
THERE IS NO FEAR.
IT USED TO BE WHEN YOU SEE
SOMEONE GET ATTACKED, THEY WOULD
RUN.
THEY WOULD TRY TO ESCAPE, THERE
IS NO REASON TO ESCAPE.
EVEN THOUGH THEY REARRESTED HIM,
THEY STILL DO NOT SAY WE WILL
MOVE THIS UP TO ATTEMPTED
MURDER.
THE VICTIM HAS BLEEDING ON HIS
BRAIN.
SO HE IS NEVER GOING TO QUITE BE
THE SAME.
HE HAS A BROKEN CHEEKBONE.
NOT TO MENTION HE WILL PROBABLY
NEVER SLEEP RIGHT FOR THE REST
OF HIS LIFE.
IF I DID SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO
SOMEBODY IT WOULD BE ATTEMPTED
MURDER PERIOD.
AND WE STILL DON'T KNOW IF THIS
GUY WILL MAKE IT THROUGH ALL OF
THIS.
THERE ARE COMPLICATIONS.
HE HAS UNBELIEVABLE AMOUNTS OF
SURGERY GOING.
BUT WHAT IT ALL COMES OUT TO AS
YOU HAVE EMBOLDENED THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT AND EVEN WITH THIS
ARREST, IT IS STILL THE SAME
MESSAGE.
THEY DID NOT PUT ANY DUE
CHARGES.
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU NEED TO SEE?
>> Judge Jeanine: THEY DID NOT
DO ANY NEW CHARGES, BUT THEY DID
IN FACT, SHE DID NOT SAY WE HAVE
ARRESTED HIM, JOEY, AND NOW WE
WILL PAY FOR WHAT HE DID.
SHE SAID WELL, IT IS A VIOLATION
OF PAROLE.
A VIOLATION OF PAROLE IS YOU
DON'T GET IN TROUBLE.
YOU GOT IN TROUBLE AND HE GOT
ARRESTED.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT NOW WHAT YOU'VE GOT ARE
THESE FLASH PARTIES OR FACEBOOK
PARTIES WHERE THEY DECIDE THAT
THEY ARE ALL GOING TO GANG UP
AND GO INTO A STORE AND
LITERALLY STRIP IT OF EVERYTHING
ON THE SHELVES.
WHERE ARE WE?
I MEAN, I DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
QUESTION TO ASK AT THIS POINT.
NOBODY EVEN STOPS THESE KIDS AND
SAYS YOU CAN'T DO THIS ANYMORE.
>> Joey: THE QUESTION I ASK IS
OF NEW YORKERS, WHICH IS HOW
MUCH DOES THIS MATTER TO YOU?
BECAUSE I GET TO GO ROGUE HERE.
AND THEY GET TO DECIDE WHO WILL
REPRESENT THEM AND WHAT LAWS
THEY KEEP.
I REMEMBER THE SAYING IN
MILITARY SCHOOL WHICH IS DON'T
APPLY A BAN AID FIX TO A
TOURNIQUET PROBLEM.
AND SO WITHOUT BEING TOO
GRAPHIC, YOU CAN KIND OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS.
WHAT HAPPENS HERE IS THIS GUY IS
IN JAIL BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF
HIS CRIME IS SIMPLY IN JAIL
BECAUSE COMMITTING A CRIME
VIOLATED HIS PAROLE, FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
AND WHAT IRKS ME THE MOST IS
THAT WE SHOW THE SCREENSHOT, THE
SCREEN POLL OF MUG SHOTS AND SAY
WHAT THIS HISTORY OF VIOLENCE HE
SHOULD BE BEHIND BARS.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, NO, WHAT
THIS ONE INCIDENT HE SHOULD BE
BEHIND BARS.
IT IS COMMON SENSE THAT IF
SOMEONE GOES OUT ON THE STREETS
WITH THE INTENT TO HARM PEOPLE,
THEY DON'T DESERVE TO BE OUT ON
THE STREET.
THAT IS A VERY SIMPLE THING.
AND IF NEW YORK LAWS ARE
STOPPING THAT FROM HAPPENING,
THEN NEW YORKERS NEED TO FIX
THIS BY GETTING NEW PEOPLE IN
OFFICE.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND IT IS
NOT JUST NEW YORK, JESSICA, IT
IS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT IS THIS CASHLESS BAIL, THE
SOCIAL JUSTICE, WORRYING MORE
ABOUT CRIMINALS THAN VICTIMS.
IN ONE SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE
ARE HAVING COFFEE AND OUTSIDE OF
A COFFEE SHOP AND A BUNCH OF
GUYS COME OUT WITH GUNS AND
EXTENDED MAGAZINES AND THEY HOLD
THEM UP BY THEIR WATCHES AND
THEIR BRACELETS DIRECTLY OFF THE
STREET FROM NEW YORK CITY
COUNCILWOMAN HAS DEFUNDED
POLICE.
WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE NOT IN
THIS FOR US?
>> Jessica: IT SEEMS LIKE
ELECTION TIME IS ONE THAT LOOKS
LIKE THAT.
AND RECALL EFFORTS ARE HAPPENING
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, AND THEY
ARE BEING PUSHED FORWARD BY
DEMOCRATS.
I WAS DOING SOME RESEARCH ABOUT
THE RECALL OF JESSICA BIEL DEAN
AND IT WAS FROM ASIAN AMERICAN
DEMOCRATS WHO WERE LIKE THIS IS
NOT OKAY ANYMORE.
AND OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS OF
HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICANS, THEY SAID,
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH ON THIS.
AND TO JOEY'S POINT ABOUT
VOTING.
I WENT TO VOTE THIS MORNING, I
LIVE IN THE NEW YORK DISTRICT,
DID EARLY VOTING IN THE DISTRICT
THAT WAS BOLD WILL de BLASIO
FOR FIVE SECONDS, BUT GOLDMAN
WAS RUNNING IN IT, THE CHIEF
PROSECUTOR AND DONALD TRUMP DID
ENDORSE HIM, SO NOW WE HAVE
VOTED FOR THE SAME CANDIDATES,
WHICH IS A LITTLE STRANGE, BUT
WHAT IS REALLY INTERESTING IN
THE DEBATE BETWEEN DAN GOLDMAN
AND IS MUCH MORE PROGRESSIVE
COUNTERPARTS WHO WERE RUNNING
WAS THAT THE PROGRESSIVE WITH
THE LEGAL AID LAWYER TALKED
OPENLY ABOUT HOW BAD ALAN BRAGG
IS, AND GOLDMAN HAD ENDORSED
ALAN BRAGG WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
FOR D.A.
SO YOU'RE SEEING PEOPLE WHO ARE
MORE TRADITIONALLY REGRESSIVE,
LEFT MODERATE DEMOCRAT ON ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE ISSUE EXCEPT FOR
CRIME AND SAYING THIS HAS TO BE
ABOUT VICTIMS, NOT ABOUT
PROTECTING CRIMINALS ANYMORE.
AND THAT'S THE TREND YOU WILL
SEE ACROSS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
>> Judge Jeanine: INCARCERATED
PERSON.
>> Tyrus: BUT NO ONE IS
INCARCERATED.
>> Jessica: THERE ARE A FEW
PEOPLE IN THERE I THINK.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND OF
COURSE WITH TYRUS, THAT CHANGE
THE LAW IN NEW YORK,